I know there's a teleprompter but
writing this out in Chateau Marmont
pencil on personalized Chateau Marmont
paper today was very meaningful for me
and even more so tonight to be in this
room with some extraordinary people
being celebrated darling Angela I want
eye contact it could we could almost be
on Facebook but we're not I can see you
you already know from the Broadway
season we shared in 2009 that I danced
and lip synced to Maine when I was a
teenager in all of your name so
deservedly as big as the title and in
the same font from the glow of Gaslight
to the warmth of mrs. Potts the mother
of Hamlet the mother of Elvis Bedknobs
broomsticks the worst pies in London
disorienting
Henry orient and facing down Dorian Gray
are you the living definition of range
when they talk about the Golden Age of
Hollywood aren't they just talking about
you these are rhetorical questions
they're not up for debate
I'm only here as a reminder that being
in the presence of Angela Lansbury is
the best possible reason to drink a
toast to our most honored lands Burien
candidate I labored over that I raised
this vessel with the pestle to the
chalice with no malice the priceless
Angela I'm so honored to you